Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today, I’m going to explain a fantasy film
called “Everyday.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
“A” is a mysterious traveling spirit,
who inhabits the bodies of a different teenager
for a single day, every day.
The movie begins as Á wakes up in a high
school boy, Justin Smith’s body.
He takes a picture of himself as he does with
everybody he has been in, and sets a timer
for 11:00 PM and 11:50 PM.
Rhiannon is Justin’s girlfriend, that he
is ignorant to.
Rhiannon is completely in love with Justin,
but he neither replies to her texts nor treats
her well.
That day, Á navigates his life as Justin
at school and meets Rhiannon, who apologizes
to him for texting too much.
Justin tells her that it’s alright, and
he should have texted her back, a total opposite
to his normal personality.
Rhiannon convinces Justin to skip school with
her, to spend more time with him.
The two sneakily run out of the school.
The whole day was magical for both of them.
They sing songs in his car, walk together
in an aquarium, run around the beach happily
and have a lot of fun.
As they walk through the park, Rhiannon tells
him about her dad’s manic episode a few
years ago and how it affected her relationship
with him.
She feels nice that Justin is interested in
her family life.
At the end of the day, as they are about to
separate, A, as Justin tells Rhiannon that
tomorrow won’t be like today.
Rhiannon however ends the day on a positive
note, citing that tomorrow is tomorrow.
The two kiss and finally separate.
Á seems to have gotten attached to Rhiannon.
It is now the next day, and Á wakes up as
a girl named Amy.
She takes a picture of herself like always
and sets an alarm.
To be closer to Rhiannon, Amy goes to her
high school as a new student.
Meanwhile, Rhiannon is distressed because
of Justin’s ignorant behaviour towards her again.
Amy meets Rhiannon, saying that she is a transfer
student, and wants Rhiannon to show her around.
The two are at the chemistry lab when Justin
comes in and complains about missing practice
the previous day.
He doesn’t seem to remember anything that
happened yesterday, which hurts Rhiannon.
Justin even blames her for him missing practice.
Amy gets furious and replies to Justin on
Rhiannon’s behalf, saying that he is unappreciative
of the only good thing going on in his life.
Rhiannon asks her to stop, while Justin looks
at her weirdly and leaves.
After the encounter, an upset Rhiannon asks
Amy to be with her friend Alexander, and leaves.
Cut to the following day.
Á wakes up as a boy named Nathan and does
his usual routine.
He goes to his computer and searches for an
address on the map.
Meanwhile, Justin and Rhiannon are at a party
where he leaves her with the keys, and goes
with his friend group.
Rhiannon is alone and awkward.
Justin completely neglects Rhiannon for the
whole night.
She is standing alone, when she sees Nathan
dancing goofily.
She can’t help but join him.
The two are dancing together, when Justin
approaches them standing protectively by Rhiannon’s side.
Nathan introduces himself as Justin’s friend,
Steve’s cousin and says that he is gay.
He even suggests being attracted to Justin,
so he goes back to his friends.
Nathan then invites Rhiannon to go outside.
They talk about Rhiannon’s type in men,
and laugh.
They talk for a long time, but Nathan has
to go before 12.
Meanwhile, Justin figures that Steve has no
cousin.
They run downstairs and chase Nathan away.
The next day, Á wakes up as a blind boy and
cannot find his phone.
So, he spends the whole day in his room.
Meanwhile, Nathan has become an internet troll,
saying that he was possessed by a devil.
Rhiannon gets a message from a random number
the next day, asking her to meet the person
in a public place alone.
She goes to the library, where she is approached
by a girl named Megan.
At first, Megan tells Rhiannon that Nathan
sent her, but then she begins to explain her
life as a moving spirit.
She reveals that she wakes up as a different
person every day, the day she went out with
Justin, she was Justin; then, she was Amy,
and the previous day, she was Nathan.
Rhiannon doesn’t believe any of this and
tries to leave, but Megan begins to recite
the thing she said to Justin on their date.
Rhiannon then assumes that Justin and everyone
else is playing a sick prank on her, but Megan
insists that she is real.
Freaked out, Rhiannon leaves the place.
The following day, she again gets a text message
from a number, and goes to meet Á in a diner.
This time it is an Asian boy waiting for her.
She quizzes him about all the things she has
done with the people’s bodies he has been
in, and he answers all of them correctly.
He then introduces himself as A, a name he
has given himself.
Á tells her that he wakes up every day in
a different body which is always near the
last body, and around the same age as him.
He doesn't know if he has parents, or where
he was born.
He has been changing bodies ever since he
was a kid.
He tries to leave as little a trace as possible
after living the day.
Á then shows her his Instagram account, where
he posts pictures of everyone he has woken up as.
Rhiannon is still a little skeptical, but
is beginning to believe him.
She tries to investigate the matter herself
and goes to visit Nathan at a Church.
He claims that he was possessed by the Devil
that day, and remembers only bits and pieces
of what happened.
When he woke up the following day, his phone
was logged into the “devil” Instagram account.
But he claims that the credentials were changed
before he could download any pictures.
Rhiannon now fully believes that Á wasn’t
lying.
The following day, she sees a girl looking
at her in the hallways and figures that it
is A. The two talk and she asks him about
Nathan.
It turns out that Á couldn’t make it to
Nathan’s house on time and had to leave
his body in a hurry.
Hence, he had forgotten to log off his Instagram
on Nathan’s phone.
Rhiannon then believes that Á had invaded
her privacy by kissing her as Justin.
He apologizes and says that he doesn’t do
that with everyone, but it felt different with her.
He felt something he has never felt before
when he was with Rhiannon that day.
For the same reason, he told her about his
secret.
Later that day, Rhiannon is at Justin’s,
when she asks him what he remembers about
that day, but he too claims that everything
is foggy.
She then asks him questions about their relationship,
but Justin is ignorant of the whole situation.
The next day, Á is a black guy named George.
He calls Rhiannon to meet him in a library,
where he pranks her by acting like he doesn’t
know who she is.
The two talk about A’s life again.
In the end, the two kiss, when George’s
overprotective mother comes by and calls Rhiannon a whore.
Rhiannon runs away in her car, smiling the
whole time.
The following day, Á is beyond surprised
to wake up in Rhiannon’s body.
She excitedly gets off the bed, and tells
herself to be cool about this.
While showering, Á makes sure to not look
at Rhiannon’s body.
At school, Justin approaches Rhiannon and
starts to kiss her.
Á is nervous, when he asks Rhiannon to come
over.
She blows up at him, telling him that he doesn’t
understand or appreciate her.
Á hopes she won’t get mad at him tomorrow
for doing that.
After school, Rhiannon goes to her dad’s
studio, something that real Rhiannon would
never do; she bonds with her dad, and he even
makes a painting of her.
Later at night, Á writes everything that
happened today in a note for Rhiannon to read
tomorrow, and goes to sleep.
Rhiannon reads the note the next day, and
goes to break up with Justin on her own.
She has finally realized that he is not good
for her.
Justin is shocked and wishes her luck before
storming away.
She then calls Á, and tells him about the
breakup.
She claims that she has never felt more clear
about a decision in her life.
The scene changes to Rhiannon and Á as a
different guy driving to her uncle's cabin in the woods.
They spend the whole day together talking
and laughing.
The two plan to meet again tomorrow, but Á
has to take the guy back to his place for
the night, so he leaves with the truck they
came in.
The next day, Rhiannon waits for him the whole
day, but Á never shows up.
In the end, she calls her mother to pick her
up in the cabin.
Her mother is mad at her, for making her drive
three hours on a workday.
The following day, we see Á wake up as a
guy named Michael who is supposed to fly to Holland.
If he goes away, he will be transferred to
somebody from Holland, and never come back,
so he runs away from the house and calls Rhiannon
to come to rescue him.
Rhiannon drives to him in her sister's car,
knocking off the driver's side mirror to escape
from Michael's mother.
She is mad at Á for abandoning her at the
cabin the day before.
Á explains that he woke up as a girl who
was having a lung transplant yesterday, so
he couldn’t come.
He wasn’t even allowed near cell phones,
so he couldn’t call either.
Later, Á takes over the body of a girl named
Kelsey, who was about to commit suicide.
Rhiannon meets him at her house and the two
see that she has already planned out a detailed suicide.
Kelsey's father would only be home at 5 in
the morning, so if Á leaves her body before
that, she will probably kill herself.
Rhiannon wants Á to live in Kelsey’s body,
until her father is home so she can get help.
Á isn’t really sure if he can do that but
tries anyway.
It is 11:59 and Á is still in Kelsey’s
body.
Kelsey's father comes home later, and Á tells
him that she needs help.
Á and Rhiannon are both happy that they could
save someone’s life.
The following day, Á has turned into a black
girl.
She meets Rhiannon who asks her to meet him
at night.
However, Á cannot be there because the girl
has a date with her boyfriend and she cannot miss it.
The next day, Á wakes up in Rhiannon's classmate
Alexander's body.
During the day, Á keeps on boasting about
how great of a guy Alexander is.
Rhiannon wants Á to stay in Alexander’s
body for some time as he did with Kelsey’s,
so they can be together for long.
Á reluctantly agrees, and livz as Alexender
for the next few days.
Á totally invades Alexander's privacy, and
declines all of his mother’s calls to enjoy
his time with Rhiannon.
That day, was Alexander’s birthday and his
family had prepared a surprise for him.
He felt bad for ignoring them all day.
They too were disappointed in him.
Á apologizes to Alexander's mother, and decides
to leave his body after informing Rhiannon tomorrow.
The next day, Á arranges a beautiful dinner
for Rhiannon.
As they talk, he reveals that he won’t be
Alexander from tomorrow as he doesn’t want
to take over his life.
He tells her that they cannot realistically
be together forever, so he wants Rhiannon
to be with Alexander, because he is a nice
guy and is perfect for her.
Realizing that this is their last night together,
Rhiannon and Á dance and talk; and spend
their last few hours together, cuddling on
Alexander’s bed.
The next morning, Á wakes up as a rich black
girl, Katie, and drives away in her nice car.
Meanwhile, Rhiannon meets Alexander at school,
who compliments her smile.
The two walk to their call together.
The movie ends as we see Á post a video on
Instagram, enjoying his life as a new person
at the central park.
Because of his unselfishness, Á decides to
leave Rhiannon's life, so that she could live
happily with someone else.
This is the definition of REAL LOVE.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching.